- I'm Paul Clifton, I'm 30 years old.
I am a sixth grade Teacher Leader,
and my salary is about $60,000.
I'm a new Teacher Leader, and so I get to
coach other teachers,
fellow math teachers,
and work on a team.
And we get to observe teachers teach,
co-teach with them, and
get into other classrooms
instead of just working in my own.
A lot of times at McGlone
we collaborate so much
and it's a great opportunity
to be a part of that.
I'm a ELS teacher.
So that means that in a classroom
I use Spanish and English to teach.
A lot of times, I'll trans language,
which is, I'll go back and forth,
between English and Spanish.
Just to help everyone understand.
We have a lot of language
learners at our school,
so it's so many students
that have the potential
to be bilingual and biliterate,
so it's so important that
we're using both languages,
And helping them understand
that Spanish has just as much
value and validity as English.
Even though I went through
the teaching college,
and everything like that,
took all the courses.
Like that first day, I was still,
I was still super nervous and
I can't say I was fully prepared.
You know, it's still progressing every day
and I don't think that it's
possible to be fully prepared,
to become a teacher.
I remember that first
day, I had this huge,
just like, nervous feeling
and scared and fear.
Those are always the best
times for you to grow.
Being able to get through, kind of like,
not even that first
day, but the first week.
After that it was like, ah man, okay.
This is what I'm supposed to be doing.
Employers and principals are
looking for people who are
really reflective and
really on their practice and
have their growth mindset, to
continue to grow and progress.
We have such a big emphasis
in our school around coaching,
and that progress you make as a teacher.
Definitely in the interview,
that's one of the main
questions that is asked.
Do we feel comfortable being videotaped?
Do we feel comfortable with,
in the moment coaching?
A lot of times your're
going to be asked to,
teach a lesson and then a few
minutes after you teach it,
reflect on that lesson and pick
out things that you did well
and what you could improve on.
So definitely,
principals are looking
for people that reflect
on their practice and are willing to grow.
I feel like being a black male
teacher in the elementary,
going into, becoming
an elementary teacher,
is really,
gave me an advantage in finding a job.
And being bilingual, so there was a lot
that I brought to the table, naturally,
that helped me find a job.
But I do recognize that it
can be tough for teachers.
Especially if you're not a
math or a science teacher.
To find a job and maintain
it and know that it's so
important for kids.
Especially now-a-days,
where they have access
to so much technology.
Did they, did they have
experiences with black males,
who are positive, that are in schools,
that are serving kids and
that are teaching with love.
I feel like without that,
it's tough or it can be really tough
for kids to see themselves being more than
what is shown to them
on TV or through music.
The amount of drive that you have to have
to become a teacher,
you would be successful
at anything, right?
Definitely having that
passion for teaching,
it's not easy, it's really difficult.
You have to teach on the fly,
you have to think and change
your instruction as you go.
You have to be humble every day,
because what your teaching isn't working,
so you have to change it up in some way.